next you're going to meet Padmasree
warrior Forbes calls her the queen of
electric car business
Padmasri is the CEO of deal and also the
chief development officer neo designs
smart autonomous vehicles and prior to
this Padma Shri held c-level positions
at Cisco as well as Motorola and is on
the board of Microsoft and Spotify thank
you for being here so I think the first
question that a lot of them really have
is you spent more than two decades and
really successful scaled companies why
Neil
so yeah that's right for over two
decades I worked I started my career
actually as an engineer I'm an engineer
I started in the semiconductors
connector industry as a line engineer
working in pubs and eventually was my
way up to become the chief technology
officer for Motorola semiconductor
business then eventually the coal
company and then moved to Cisco in 2008
and I was a CTO first and then CSO and
then eventually CTO and CSO and I left
and Cisco about a year and a half ago I
left in September of 2015 when I left I
didn't know what I was going to do but I
knew that what I didn't want to do I
knew I didn't want to do the same job
twice in other words I didn't want to go
as into another large tech company
in a c-level position because I felt
like I have done that in two very large
companies I this time wanted to go
somewhere where I could impact the whole
industry and change the whole industry
so I was kind of thinking I wanted to
start my own company even in the
education vertical or in the
transportation with vertical both I felt
were industries that have by and large
been stagnant and have always had
technology on the periphery never
central to the industry and then I
joined the Neill we work on
building autonomous electric vehicles
but the focus is really on how we would
all spend our time when we're not
driving anymore so the focus is really
about how do we improve people's how do
we give people time back from driving
and freeing you from the chores of
driving so we focus a lot of users on
user experience it's a fascinating time
to be really in this industry and
rethink everything yeah and I thought of
her like one of the things we had
discussed before you said that even
though the industry you know the car
seems like something that men purchase
he said actually the consumer buying
decision in most many cases is done by
women so how do you bring that in the
product design or as you think about you
know the evolution of the car even under
neo like how do you think about building
a team out on that yeah so when when I
started in this role I didn't know
anything about building cars I you know
obviously was a consumer and not really
a car guy but I loved I loved I think of
it as a consumer product so we spent
about six months doing a lot of user
research you know what do people buy
vehicles for what do they look for
and it's interesting actually in the
United States more than 50% of the
buyers for vehicles are women and many
of the women that we interviewed said
that even when they go to a dealership
today and they go with their spouse or
boyfriend and that person says this my
wife or my partner is actually buying
the car in the dealership the sale is
actually made to the man and they ignore
the woman they talk to the guys and they
tell them about all the features that
they think the men like and and so that
was one interesting fine and the second
thing we found was women always struggle
because they're sold minivan and the
labels soccer moms and you know and
ignore the professional side of what a
woman won't and many of us work and have
families and so many people told us I
don't want to be a I don't want to drive
a vehicle that kind of pigeonholes me in
the soccer mom image I want something
that is also beautiful in the vehicle
and is got space inside for my children
or my my bags or whatever so there
needs were not being met in the product
category and this is the largest buying
power in the country today for vehicles
so it was sort of like interesting to
think how a one of the most aspirational
consumer product completely ignored
more than half the population and more
than half the demographic that's
actually consuming that product so we
are taking a lot of these factors into
our design criteria as we look at it
obviously never build a product for a
particular gender but it's more for the
utility and what people are looking for
so I think that's that was a big
eye-opener for me and it's very true I
think you have to either choose between
a beautiful car but it's very compact
and has no space or something that's
giant and looks ugly but isn't anything
that's exactly so where do you think
self-driving is headed and what is your
vision for Neil so we are targeting to
have what is known in the industry as a
level 4 subscribing car by 2020 meaning
that that vehicle will be fully capable
of driving itself but we are building
our car with the steering and pedals and
so to allow you to drive if you want to
drive it and we think that actually
allows us to overcome any regulation
barriers that might get in the way
because it is a human in the loop and
you are driving I think fully autonomous
level 5 vehicles are probably further
away maybe 2025 maybe even 2030
expectations maybe I think the
technology will be there I think to me
the three axes that have to all come
together one is the technology has to be
matured and developed and be reliable
and safe the second is the cost of the
technology has to come down and it will
come down over time where the lidar and
radars and sensors have to come down in
the compute platform very powerful in
this vehicle and I thought it's actually
human behavior itself right like my
generation a lot of people we grew up
where we were taught a particular way to
drive and you have to take a driver's
license test and you pass the test and
you hold the wheel and you're taught how
to hold the wheel now there will be a
generation coming now right who will
bypass that they don't need to drive and
so if there will be a transition period
just as we went in the mobile Internet
yes
and so iPhone is now celebrating
healthier rightness so before iPhone I
where i worked at Motorola phones are
very different and we didn't expect
something like a phone to look like a
smart phone back then similarly I think
cars in the future will be very very
different so all these three things I
think will intersect in the future will
be very exciting for all of us imagine I
work in San Jose
my company's there and I was coming up
here imagine if I could just sit back
and do whatever I wanted to do take a
nap on you know instead of worrying
about traffic and driving yeah I've seen
the video of your product which is very
exciting I can't wait for the guy oh
yeah now you don't you know you be at
successful companies but we've also
built them at scale and you've talked a
lot about how great teams are what makes
a company great so what tactical advice
you have for founders here in terms of
their first 10 or those first 50 hires
because you've trust a lot about how
that is really important in how you
build a company culture that you also
treasure yeah I think when you're a
founder of a company there are I think
it's much harder by the way to start a
company than to be in a big company and
lead a big company in the following ways
when I started at Neil
I was employee number 16 there were 15
people that were kind of quality there
but I didn't I think I only had like one
engineering person and we had two
trailers in a parking lot in San Jose
and you basically are starting from
nothing in a vision and I think so to me
tactically the first 10 first 10 hires
20 hires 50 highest hundred hires are
very very important in my company I
personally interviewed the first 150
people that we hired and we made offers
to because the first hundred people hire
the next thousand people and if you want
to scale the company each of them will
hire 10 people and so your bar has to
continue to remain very very high so my
advisors as a founder really pay
attention to the people that you're
bringing in I think the previous big
speaker talked about it I love the way
she said it's better to have a hole in
the organization than an [ __ ] so I
think it's like very very true I think
you really have to be very
be selective and look for the right kind
of talent but also that I kind of a pity
the second thing that I watch out for
and this I realized as we were scaling
now we are about 350 people in the
company you know one of the other things
that happens is as you scale the
organization you go from like hundred
people to 300 people at that stage
you're not hiding anymore your leaders
are hiring and the tendency would be for
them to bring people data right and so
you create these islands of micro
culture which you don't want to have so
in my company we have a rule that every
hire has to have a diverse panel that
hires the people so diverse in terms of
the gender it can be all non male panel
or an all-female panel that interviews
does the interviewing but also people
that are from the hiring group but also
people from outside the group that can
ask people different questions
so obviously you ask you know in our
case we look for a lot of specific
technical skills and you know so you
test them for this technical skill but
people from finance or corpnet also
interview them to ask them general
questions so we look for technical depth
behavioural leadership skills and so you
ask them things like in your life what's
the toughest thing you faced and how did
you overcome that has may not really
have direct relevance to the role
because one of the things we believe is
the person's true character is tested
when they're faced with their very
traumatic situations how did you
overcome that so we ask things like that
and then we make decisions so that's the
second primary tactical advice that I
would give because we actually learned
it by the way the hard way we were doing
it and we found we were creating micro
cultures where people were hiring from
the place they came from and so soon we
had like this group that group and these
little islands which we'd all stuck
together and then the other thing I
would say is culture is extremely
important and it starts from the very
from the very beginning so in my company
one Wednesday a month and we pick
Wednesday because happens to be the
middle of the week we take time out four
to six o'clock in the afternoon we call
it team time and we go to our cafeteria
the whole company comes and we do some
fun activity and you know it's not just
to have fun but be the intent behind
that is to institutionalise the fact
that it's okay to take a break we don't
want people to burn out everybody works
hard we have to take care of ourselves
when we do this and we do this as a
company we all take a break together and
we're on a very tight pressure right now
they're shipping the car is going into
production so people team that under a
lot of pressure so we still do this and
then you know we still do two hours you
know and it's legitimate take a break
the second reason we do it is allows
people from different functions to come
together so you don't become siloed in
the company and so the intent is that
but we obviously don't do it we don't
state that we do some fun activity and
team activity so in it that's one simple
way you can build something fun in the
culture it's so people look forward to
it it actually gets fairly competitive
we have people rotating to host stream
time and so everybody comes up with
their own team sometimes it's a
competition it's a treasure hunt it's
kind of something goofy one day we build
toy cars and we race them to leave each
car goes so vehicle engineering team in
my company was very competitive and they
were actually the software team won the
race which is interesting so I think
they do things like this or that
that I think it's very important as you
scale the company of the thing on the
right things and you also have quite a
distributed team player graphically so
how do you make sure that they are all
sort of aligned and with a shared
purpose solution yeah this is
interesting our company also has a very
different model we we are what we call a
global startup and if we figure this out
I think they'll be okay stereos selling
a new very we taught in business schools
and banded the thesis is this you know
we feel like the two biggest markets are
China and us for vehicles and each one
is going through a major transformation
in China it's a big movement from
internal combustion to EVs now the
largest TV market in the world and the
US with rapidly adopting autonomy and
self-driving cars
so when we started the company we said
okay how do we create a company
structure that can win in most markets
and today it's very difficult to do that
so we started two companies essentially
the China company in a US company and we
share very capital in terms of things
like manufacturing and supply chain and
design studio the car design studio
it has pluses and minuses right now one
of the complex things is to manage you
know the requirements that we develop
technology for the company in China they
support us for manufacturing how do we
keep everybody coordinated so it again
goes back to culture and values we
describe values for the company for very
simple values we say its vision its
action its care and honesty and so we go
back and that way that's interpreted in
China is very different and we're
obviously but we go back to that and
then we make sure rules are very clear
which team is doing what and that we're
not stepping on each other's toes so
we'll see how it wasn't you know it's
sort of an experiment in its own way
yeah I also want to go back and sort of
trace your career but because that's
something which is really fascinating so
you did your engineering from IIT Delhi
in chemical engineering and then went to
Cornell how did you make the decisions
from that to go to Motorola yeah so I'm
a chemical engineer academia academic
background is in chemical engineering my
master's degree was doing materials and
so when I I was actually when I came to
the u.s. from India as a graduate
student I came on a student visa my goal
that time I thought I wanted to be a
professor I was going to do my PhD and
go back to India and teach and then it
was quite accidental that I ended up
working for Motorola it's a very funny
story I actually I don't know if you
know Korra Cornell is in upstate New
York and I left a snowstorm and came to
interview with Motorola back then in
Arizona no bright sunshine and I said
God and I was from India back then I
wasn't used to snow and stuff and said
okay whatever job they give me I'm
moving here I'm going to take a break
from my PhD and I thought I'd work for
you and go back and I never did because
I really found working and creating
concrete products was to me actually
much more interesting so as I said I
started as a line engineer and what's my
way up to become the chief technology
officer saved up for 23 years yeah I
stayed there for 23 years and you know
but back then Motorola was a very
diverse company so I got to do many
different jobs every
two years almost I was doing something
very different I started in
manufacturing then went into technology
transfer and then research and
eventually became CTO so you and then
did you come to Silicon Valley for Cisco
right so I moved to Silicon Valley in
2008 I moved to become the CTO for Cisco
got it so you've been an engineer you
know in the late 1980s you've been in
the valley now for a while has anything
changed being a womanizer
so they're very few women engineers I'd
love to see more women engineers which I
think in the technical areas they still
the ratios are very very roughly the
same I think when I went to school it
was about 14% in engineering and now
it's about the same so in some ways it
hasn't changed in at all you know if you
just look at the numbers in the last 20
years it's still very difficult I think
for women in technical field I've been
an engineer pretty much my whole career
I just moved to different roles in
engineering I just forget Microsoft with
their with their Women Engineers and I
think you know roughly the numbers are
the same across multiple companies so I
mean if you just look at that you feel
like ok nothing's really changed the
fact that now we are speaking up more is
I think better that has changed I think
in the past probably we would not have
said all the things we are saying and
calling out and I think that's great we
should continue to do more more of that
I think we should let anybody it's no
matter what level they are in any
company get away with things that
sometimes they think they have a license
we did away with that I'm very proud of
I think in just the last year we've read
and we've all followed all of the
stories that have been coming out and
not story is a reality actually right
which is shocking in some ways and you
think like wow but in other ways you
feel like we knew this was happening now
we are acknowledging this is happening
and now calling it out and holding
people accountable I think that's a
great step forward now we need to say
how do we stop these things from
happening in the first place right yeah
and as a woman and today you've talked
about this before how did you you know
did you feel you had to behave like a
man sometime
we'll change your style of work
absolutely when I started I was I think
there are probably very few engineers in
factories and semiconductor factories I
started as a factory engineer we were
actually told to dress a particular way
we couldn't wear any color we were told
to wear I think it was stories I wear
gray and kind of blended like I did a
wall and and again I came from India I
grew up with a lot of color it was very
alien for me to be that way but I forced
myself to do it because I thought like
oh my gosh I have to do this otherwise I
won't get a job or I won't be you know
recognized for the work I do but it made
me very uncomfortable and you know after
a few months of that I stopped you know
I said I can't be where I'm not really
as a person and now I always talk about
how women should be women first whatever
it is that makes you comfortable you
should dress the way you want to dress
and then you know let your work define
you I mean in my company actually we do
this at team time one of the things men
and women do this by the way all of us
do this as human being when we introduce
ourselves notice this we all introduce
ourselves with a job title and say hi
I'm hot mystery warrior and CEO phone'll
we never say who we are as a person so
when we hire new employees when we do a
team time we introduce all our new hires
and we have them come up and say one
some fun fact about themselves I love
cooking I have a two-year-old or I play
the guitar I love rock climbing I have a
motorcycle that I love to ride on
whatever it is right now why don't we
say that about ourselves and you know we
have to give ourselves permission to be
authentic and who we are so that's
something that I encourage everyone to
do for human women see and given all the
recent events what tactical advice would
you have for companies to sort of
address this you know what can
organizations even you know founders
hear what can they do from they want to
make sure yeah firstly I think have your
pulse on the organization start an
excuse to say I didn't know this was
happening it's obviously impossible to
keep track of everything and when
someone raises an issue make it a
priority make it you know we in my
company
now we're 350 people you know I have a
complete open policy people come talk to
me and when they talk to me it's not
that I just don't ignore it you know if
they're complaining about something we
try to do something you know we fix it
they can't fix it we have to go back and
say we can't fix it I think it's very
important if you're the founder and CEO
you have personal accountability for
everything that happens in your company
and you have to take accountability for
that thank you and I think it's
important to have a follow up price DMV
you know there are lots of complaints
like oh the cafeterias too cold today or
the food came late some things are small
some things are more serious but you
have to pay attention to all of them so
I think don't minimize that and I think
actually I feel like we compete for
talent right in the space we're in it's
very difficult to find the right kind of
talent a lot of people come to work for
our company for the mission for their
culture I think it is definitely a
factor now well thank you so much for
taking the time today and for sharing
these insights thank you so much thanks
for having us
[Music]
[Applause]
you